[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le
débrief des questions au gouvernement et
pour commencer cette image qui a pu
surprendre 1 celle du premier ministre
longuement applaudie par sa majorité
avant de prendre la parole
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
pourquoi ces applaudissements et bien on
peut y voir une réponse à la polémique
déclenchée par gilles legendre
dans une note confidentielle le
président du groupe en marche à
l'assemblée à envisager tout simplement
qu' edouard philippe soit remplacé à son
poste de premier ministre à matignon
et cela n'a pas plu à tout le monde et
puis autre explication possible à ses
applaudissements tout simplement la
question qui vient d'être posée à
edouard philippe question assez musclé
posée par la députée les républicains
virginie duby müller sur un sujet
brûlant celui du racisme et des
violences policières
107 c'est le nombre de violences que
subissent chaque jour nos forces de
l'ordre en france
face à ce constat dramatique le premier
flic de france a choisi de se soumettre
à la haine anti-flic prêt à bafouer la
présomption d'innocence pour donner des
gages à la haine tel françois hollande
avec léonard da votre gouvernement
accepte que la justice soit rendue par
la rue ou sur les réseaux sociaux plutôt
que dans un tribunal
il est indispensable de lutter contre
toutes les formes de racisme ou qu'elle
sévisse mais il est impensable de
laisser accuser l'état et la police de
racisme de laisser l'amérique anisé la
france alors que notre histoire n'a rien
de comparable
alors je vous le demande en reprenant
les termes de votre ministre de
l'éducation nationale etes-vous la
république en marche où le
communautarisme en vadrouille
allez vous défendre l'honneur de la
police en refusant qu'elle soit livré à
la vindicte populaire
etes-vous de ceux qui défendent les
forces de l'ordre ou de ceux qui veulent
la mettre à genoux je voudrais prendre
votre question dans ce qu'elle a de plus
sérieux et de moi pardon mais bassement
polémique le plus sérieux c'est la
réponse que notre pays apporte aux actes
racistes
g je les dis madame la députée respect
et confiance dans la police nationale et
je pense que nos concitoyens ont respect
et confiance dans la police nationale
mais parce que j'ai respect et confiance
dans la police nationale
je porte avec le ministre de l'intérieur
une exigence vis-à-vis de tous les
dépositaires de l'autorité publique
la police nationale la france la france
la police nationale la gendarmerie ne
sont pas racistes mais chaque fois
chaque fois qu'un acte chaque fois qu'un
acte ou un propos avérés et raciste
alors il est important que l'ensemble de
notre pays réagisse vous êtes d'accord
sur ce point
moi aussi c'est ce que nous disons
respect confiance exigences c'est la
ligne qui est porté par ce gouvernement
c'est la ligne qui doit prévaloir c'est
la ligne sur laquelle toujours je me
battrai
pas moins de cinq questions ont porté
sur ce thème des violences policières et
à linverse des républicains la gauche
elle demande au gouvernement de se
montrer plus ferme à l'encontre des
policiers qui sont mis en cause pour
leur comportement lors de cette séance
le groupe socialiste a demandé une
commission d'enquêté sur les violences
policières quant à la députée communiste
est la faucille ont elles souhaitent que
le gouvernement aille au delà des
mesures annoncées hier
ces violences policières souvent
racistes sont une réalité et l abîme en
profondeur notre démocratie
elles laissent des familles endeuillées
et l enseigne la défiance enregistrement
racistes antisémites homophobes appel à
la guerre civile
interpellation à l'ile-saint-denis
rappelant les années papon passage à
tabac de gabriel 14 ans c'est
insupportable et il y a un problème dans
notre police républicaine le nier c'est
la promesse certaines d'une dangereuse
impasse
monsieur le ministre comment
comptez-vous rétablir la confiance dans
la police sans mettre fin à l'impunité
de ces individus violents sans
transformer l'igpn en instance
impartiale et indépendante sans vous
attaquez réellement aux contrôles au
faciès dont vous niez encore l'ampleur
la police n'est pas raciste
oui il y a eu des faits et vous les avez
cités oui il y a eu des faits madame la
députée qui ont été sanctionnés des
faits ou des actes ont pu être commis et
qui se rattache aurassi des propos
racistes ont pu être retenues et des
sanctions ont été mises en oeuvre des
procédures judiciaires sont ouvertes et
le ministre de l'intérieur l'a annoncé
hier
nous irons encore plus loin puisqu'il y
aura désormais quand les faits sont
avérés des suspensions automatiques et
bien évidemment justifier ça c'est
quelque chose de nouveau
non madame la députée la police n'est
pas violente la police exerce une
violence légitime
lorsqu'elle est prise à partie la police
n'est pas raciste la police n'est pas
violente
cette police et celle qui tous les jours
lutte contre la délinquance lutte contre
le terrorisme lutte contre les trafics
de stupéfiants et protège la liberté de
manifester des manifestants comme ils le
font
jour cette question à présent comment
aider les élèves qui ont décroché de
l'école pendant la période du
confinement
la députée lrm anissa kheder
s'inquiètent plus particulièrement du
sort des jeunes issus des quartiers
prioritaires
vous allez voir que julien de normandie
leur propose des colonies de vacances un
peu particulière la question
fondamentale c'est est-ce que après ce
printemps triste ce printemps
sacrificielle nous souhaitons un était
heureux 1 et et d'opportunité ou pas
avec jean michel blanquer r nous avons
décidé de mettre en place un dispositif
innovant et ce projet c'est de permettre
à deux cent mille enfants des quartiers
de partir de leur quartier pour aller
dans d'autres territoires et d'avoir des
colonies apprenantes ses colonies
apprenantes le principe est assez simple
c'est de permettre d'avoir à la fois ce
moment d'évasion ces nouveaux horizons
géographiques culturelles mais en même
temps d'avoir un rattrapage scolaire
lorsque ce rattrapage scolaire est
nécessaire nous proposerons que vous
puissiez adopté un financement de
l'ordre de 80 millions d'euros de 80
millions d'euros pour pouvoir les
financer
enfin cette séance a été l'occasion pour
trois députés de faire leurs adieux
trois députés qui viennent d'être élu
maire au premier tour des municipales et
qui quitte donc les mystiques pour
respecter le non cumul des mandats
il s'agit de francis vercamer luc
carvounas et laurent furst ce n'est pas
sans émotion que j'interviens pour la
dernière fois dans cet hémicycle ayant
été réélu maire de la ville de molsheim
en alsace mesdames et messieurs je vous
invite tous à venir visiter cette
commune alsacienne
je veux vous dire mes chats collègues au
moment de quitter le parlement après
neuf années de mandat que je vous
adresse à tous un salut républicains à
votre ensemble de mes collègues sur tous
les bons de notre assemblée après la
crise sociale des gilet jaune et la
crise sanitaire du coc vide
j'aimais juste le veut que l'état prenne
enfin conscience que nos territoires
sont la deuxième jambe sur laquelle doit
s'appuyer notre pays dans l'intérêt de
tous nos concitoyens et à vous tous mes
chers collègues
n'oubliez jamais la belle mission qui
est la vôtre celle de porter la voix de
la nation et de réaliser
le meilleur pour nos compatriotes je
vous souhaite à tous et à toutes bonnes
chances je remercie d'abord de préciser
qu'il s'agit pour moi aussi de ma
dernière intervention dans cet hémicycle
je viens d'être élu maire de hem dans le
nord et je m'apprête donc à quitter les
bancs de cette assemblée dont j'ai
l'honneur de faire partie depuis 2002 je
citerai andré diligent qui fut député
avant de devenir maire de roubaix puis
sénateur qui écrivait on n'est jamais
sûr d'avoir raison mais on sait si on a
été sincère et si on a su rester fidèle
à sa part de vérité
edouard philippe connaît bien cette
tentation des municipales puisqu'il est
lui-même candidat dans la ville du havre
et vous allez voir qu'il a d'ailleurs
adressé à un clin d'oeil à ces trois
députés
permettez moi à travers la réponse que
je vais apporter à la question que vous
me posez de commencer par féliciter tous
ceux qui manquent de cette assemblée
ayant été brillamment élu aux élections
municipales font le choix de consacrer à
temps plein
leur vie politique future à ses
fonctions municipales que vous
connaissez monsieur le député pour les
avoir déjà exercé pendant longtemps je
respecte ce choix
et je le comprends voilà edouard
philippe où la tentation des municipales
c'est l'image de fin de ce débrief on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine
[Musique]